-Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much going on
right now.
Everyone's gearing up
for the midterms.
The World Series is heating up.
The top 10 songs in the country
are all by Taylor Swift.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, Stouffer's is releasing
its own Bloody Mary mix
that tastes like lasagna.
There's a lot to go over.
Let's just jump in,
cover it all at once.
It's time for "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
First up, the midterms.
They're less than a week away.
Republicans are trying
to win back control
of the House and Senate,
while the Democrats
want to hold on to both.
Two sides going head-to-head,
kind of like the World Series.
Tonight was Game 4 between
the Phillies and the Astros.
Both teams are doing
everything they can
to prove that they're the best
in the country.
Speaking of the best
in the country, Taylor Swift --
She's the first artist
to hold all top 10 spots
in the Billboard 100 at once.
That must feel good.
And if you want
to feel good, too,
maybe don't try Stouffer's new
lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
It's vodka mixed with lasagna
topped with a rim
of shredded mozzarella.
It's the perfect drink for
anyone who wants to black out
and forget all about
the midterms.
It's a stressful time.
President Biden has been
touring the country
trying to rally support
for Democrats,
but the only tour most people
care about is Taylor's.
She announced her Eras Tour
this week.
Tickets aren't available yet,
but Swifties
are losing their minds,
foaming at the mouth,
which are also side effects
when you drink
Stouffer's lasagna-flavored
Bloody Mary mix.
Look at this thing.
It's like a lasagna smoothie.
It's like a V8 from hell.
If you drink one of these,
you might get the runs.
You need runs
if you want to win.
Philly's going to go nuts
if they win, by the way.
Police are already racing
to grease up light poles.
Speaking of races and polls,
the midterms.
Dr. Oz is running for office
in Pennsylvania,
and you'll be
in a doctor's office
after drinking
alcoholic lasagna.
In conclusion, here we go.
Time to vote.
What a show.
Just no.
This has been a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]